I don't see what winning the court actually provides you with
other than just like twisting the knife even >> You're
a complete utter psychopath. I just I'm just going to sit here
like a jester as the world burns.
>> Bro is opening new fronts like he's Israel. No, literally.
What the
Yes, as the title says, Idubbbz confirms he's officially being
sued. There's officially a lawsuit from Ethan Klein. It is official.
I am being sued by Ethan Klene in the courts of Calgary, Alberta
for defamation.
I do plan on fighting against this, but for now, it is in the
hands of the courts and our attorneys. I will say
it it worries me what it means for the
commentary community
and uh especially the Canadian commentary community.
PPP, what do you think of this PPP? That's what he's saying right
now, right? Hey PPP, what do you think of this PPP? Hey PPP,
if slander is so easy to sue for in Canada, aren't you man? Aren't
you totally, completely, and utterly? What's going to prevent
the Quartering from coming at you with like five different lawsuits,
buddy? That's probably what Idubbbz is trying to say here, right?
I'm sorry that the stream is so short. I wish I could give you
a lot more grease,
but I will resume
the regularly scheduled content.
This ratman can get for real. I hope you don't like any other
commentary channel. I just I hope you don't like any other commentary
channel because what he's getting sued for is nothing. And so
anybody who's rich, if you if you like people criticizing Ethan
Klein, you like people criticizing anyone who's got probably
a any seven figure net worth,
all everybody is now like massively chilled. All the content
that you watch, I know you watch Chud. I know you're all in in
all of these communities. You're you're just in every one of
these communities
>> Again, I'm sorry it's so short.
But we will be back and I appreciate you being here for this
important
Have a good day everyone.
Feel like Ethan's lawyers would have had to put other stuff in
it. Like what
what is Idubbbz even done? Dude, Idubbbz cried about Ethan being
like a bad person or something. What in the what even is it?
What would he even put in there? Like, yeah, it's not about It's
one of those things where it's like, dude, I don't care if people
suck. I don't care if this guy sucks.
Something that's like ruining a huge content sphere on the internet.
That's why you don't support this. You You don't go, "Oh, well,
it's funny." No, you are a loser. You are a total complete and
utter loser. Go watch Nicholas Dioro, you loser. Don't come in
my community and go, "Oh, well, I just don't like them, so I
want like anything bad to happen to them." Off. Go watch anybody
else.
Hold on. We get a We get a Chippy video on this. Hold on. We
got a Chippy video. Let's check out Chippy real quick. He just
published He just put up a video on >> Yesterday we talked
about Ethan Klein losing his case tentatively, of course, to
Denims. And today, we're talking about him launching a new case
against Idubbbz. I am being sued by Ethan Klein in the courts
of Calgary, Alberta for defamation. This is officially the fifth
lawsuit that Ethan Klein has engaged in. Sixth, if you count
that Denim has two separate lawsuits. Now, what exactly is the
defamation? What exactly did Idub say that was so defamatory?
Destiny, quick daily reminder. Ethan from H3H3 is likely a who
has his own children. And it's very important to remember this.
Idubbbz, even when showing this, says that he does not believe
the allegation. >> It's okay. Okay. So, I do want to say
I don't agree with what's being said in this um comment here.
Uh but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should be
addressed because it's a big bold accusation that's very up.
>> Is there anything that someone could disagree with with
this? Sure. You could say it's too edgy to show a comment like
that. But if H3 really has a problem with that comment, he should
go to the source of who made that comment rather than suing Idubbbz
who simply said, "Hey, I don't agree with this comment, but someone
should address this." Listen, I was frustrated when the cease
and desist happened, but the fact that this is actually going
to court is ridiculous. A comment that Idubbbz did not make is
getting him in court right >> Lost your mind,
>> man. I [sighs] It sucks cuz I don't even want to point
out like other things that are going on. You know what I mean?
Like I I feel like there are other people at risk of having this
exact same thing happen to them. And it's almost difficult to
even point it out because I feel like I'd be painting a target
on their backs. You know what I mean? I can't even really like
speak freely now. Like I'd like to say, "Oh, well, here's like
some other stuff that seems like it would be concerning." Like
I would be very concerned if I was doing this kind of content
right now, but then it just feels like I'm painting a target
on people's back. You know what I mean? Like I don't know. It's
It's already just in terms of what I want to say right now on
this stream, it's already having an effect. It's annoying. Now,
what's interesting is the way that he even characterizes it.
He does reference that slap laws in the United States would likely
get this case thrown out. >> If he lived in California,
I wouldn't even bother threatening to sue him because of
in our great state. We have anti-SLAP laws that make it extraordinarily
difficult.
Do you hear what the this >> He's literally saying this
is a strategic lawsuit against public participation and I would
never file it where there are laws against strategic lawsuits
against public participation.
If if those laws exist somewhere, I will not sue you if you live
there. Imagine admitting you're this big a piece of dude. It's
it's so gross, man. If you enjoyed today's video and you want
to see more like it, leave a like, comment, and subscribe. And
uh well wishes to Idubbbz. What what an insane thing that he's
going through and what an insane thing this is for the community.
If you make content online, if you criticize people with money,
if you criticize people with power, influence, uh they will do
this to you. And H3 is very clearly one of these people that
does not care about open and free expression. He cares about
silencing dissenting
>> Okay, so Nick covers, we're going to do the Nick response
to the Idubbbz thing real fast and then we'll probably keep moving,
keep it pushing. >> Actually, there is kind of the new
Idubbbz drama that we can talk about. I don't know why I ordered
it this way, but we have the Hotep tweet showing that Idubbbz
is now being sued by Ethan Klein. We're going to go over some
brief more recent Idubbbz before we check out Nick Nobody's video.
And obviously, I mean, you guys know my position on this. I think
this is stupid.
Um, I think this is just entirely spite driven and it doesn't
really make any sense to me to do, but whatever. That's that's
the direction he's going in. Uh, I I give the disavowel or whatever
that I told you I'd give if he did it. >> You can't even
say anything beyond guys. I will hold to my word from before.
I will give you the disavowel.
I will give you I give the disavow that I said I would do before.
Guys, this is kind of bad. I give the disavow or whatever.
Okay, it is >> he fired this up. Was it uh today?
I think it was before we went live >> official.
I am being sued by Ethan Klene in the courts of Calgary, Alberta.
>> This is like the Canadian lawsuit we've heard so much
about >> for defamation.
They say anything since the cease and desist? I don't think they
did. I'm pretty sure they basically said nothing since the cease
and desist, right?
Like I don't think they've been going crazy or anything. In fact,
I believe they apologized because of the cease and desist. No,
I thought that was why they apologized was because there was
a cease and desist sent to them.
>> I will say, >> and by the way, this is the comment
related to Ethan's kids that was uh embedded into the stream
like the Destiny quote
it it worries me what it means for the
commentary community
and uh especially the Canadian commentary community. >> Is
there a high Canadian commentary community that exists right
now? Again, I see what he's saying here, but we're we've kind
of like this has kind of been the reality, right? We're we're
in the middle of that. Doesn't mean that I think it's great.
Doesn't mean that I think it's like a good thing that's occurring,
but like to act like this is like the first of many or whatever.
We're like this is the many of many. We're in the many times.
This is the same totally
response that people had to the whole Destiny doxing campaign.
Nicholas and Billy explicitly, oh, I guess everybody just doxes
now, guys. This is like just the way it is now. Everybodyes each
other. It's kind of crazy, right? It's like bad. But what are
we supposed to do? Everyone does it. It's like normal. No, it's
not.
No, it's not. And all you got to do is call it the people doing
it. All you got to do is call it the people doing it like vehemently
and often
and basically make them persona nongrada. If you're not going
to operate within the rules, you off. That's what needs to happen
to Ethan Klein. That's what needs to happen to people who operate
this way. It's so easy to understand. And this this response
right here is total.
Oh well guys, people just been suing each other forever. No.
No, that's not true.
Absolutely not true. And certainly I would hope that if that
were the case that Nicholas would declined to suck the of anybody
doing it. Okay. But he has not declined to suck Ethan Klein's.
He will not stop doing it. So that's all I'm asking for. Just
stop stop being a part of that whole thing. It's it's already
bad.
I know you got called out for the distance thing, too, but distance
Make it at least defensible for some people. Man, Becket is dying
every second you keep sitting here like a fat
refusing to actually call Ethan Klein out for what he is. A latigious
disgusting freak. You're making Becket cry. Okay, Becket's trying
to sweep for you all over the place. Please just help Becket
out. He cannot hold you up for much longer, Nicholas. Okay, you're
crushing this guy. You're crushing this
Come on, man. Like, do you think that if Denims went forward
with her lawsuit on Ethan, they'd be like, "This is a bad moment
for commentary on YouTube right now. I forgot. Was hers defamation
or was hers copyright?" That was so long. Hers was defamation.
Unfortunately, she like that was
was that I think as soon as Ethan apologized like if you want
to send a cease and desist because you think somebody's lying
about you, I understand doing that. What I don't understand is
somebody goes, "Well, yeah, I was lying about you. I did I you
know I do have to actually walk that back. And then you still
sue them. That's what happened with the items thing, right? They
basically walked it back. They basically said like, "Yeah, I
apologize. I shouldn't have been doing this. My bad." And he
still sued them
long ago. Well, I don't Dude, there has to be some way to hold
people in check for like outright lying. And I do think a cease
and desist to say, "Hey, you're lying about me. Don't just lie
about me." Right. That's that's a different thing in my opinion.
Now, with the e with the Noah Samson thing, he got a cease and
desist and Noah Samson told him to kick rocks. I think that's
cuz Noah Samson knows his speech is protected. So, it's it's
going to come down to like an actual like determination of facts
there.
Anyway, we keep going. >> Like if Assan [__]
sued
Sorry, sure, sure, sure. Maybe Idubbbz didn't say he lied. Idubbbz
said like, "I'm sorry that I even brought it up. It was insensitive
or something, right? Didn't he apologize in some way?" He didn't
say he like said it. He said he didn't say it. He didn't believe
it, but it was like insensitive. Anyway, I thought he apologized
somehow, but I don't really remember it. So, I should probably
not even say that. I thought the whole impression I had was that
he apologized. Nicholas talked about him apologizing. That's
the impression I remember, but I have not watched it in whatever
weeks since it originally happened. So, difficult for me to say.
>> Pegasus like he's been angling on YouTube to do where
they'd be like, "This is a precedent setting lawsuit."
We're kind of just in that. The >> Oh, the president was
not set. And the precedent that was set, by the way, like maybe
lawsuits, maybe it's not a precedent setting lawsuit in some
of these cases. Certainly the copyright stuff was precedent setting.
What who's setting the precedent? Is this fat who refuses to
call it the people doing it who would have done so before?
What did he think of the What did he think of the lawsuits against
Carl Job? Did he like those that Billy Mitchell was running?
I don't think until Billy Mitchell won, I don't think he liked
Billy Mitchell very much at all. Right. Wasn't he totally on
Carl Job's side? Like, I think Nicholas has broadly been against
any silence of criticism via the legal system up until this point.
That's the precedent, Nicholas, is that you're suddenly on the
side of the person who's doing this to chill criticism, to chill
speech, and you're not even just a little bit on side with it.
You're literally calling for blood.
Like, come on, man. You weren't even just a little bit on like
on board. You were really You were all the way on board. >> Behind
the scenes while G. >> No, it's the time to escalate. No,
I'm sorry. you know, you only get to do this for so long. No,
it's the time for lawsuits. It's the time to escalate. It's the
time to go for blood. No, it absolutely is. I'm sorry. >> So,
where is he saying like, "Oh, well, this this is how all lawsuits
are. This is how it all is. This is the current environment."
It sounds like he's talking about escalating, going to a new
place. Sounds like he's he doesn't give a about whether or not
it's the environment we're in or anything like that. He is just
like, "No, they with you. You have to hit them back. You have
to go after them, Ethan. You have to go after them now." I just
can't believe the tone shift. The tone shift's nuts.
>> Like if Hassan Per sued Pegasus like he's been angling
on YouTube to do, would they be like this is a precedent setting
lawsuit? >> No. But I would call Hassan a for suing Pegasus.
I even I went out of my way to say no. I think I think Hassan
is like probably doing something wrong just by reviewing this
in the Tony is I think there's something here where he's trying
to get right up to the line and I'm making it clear that hey
if you go over this line you I was incredibly
aggressive in calling that out and saying no no no don't do that
don't do that this guy doesn't really have any power he's an
absur absurd loser he will lose he will lose the precedent's
been set lawsuits are >> commentary community
and uh especially the Canadian. >> Yeah. Know, it's just
too far for me. But if I didn't like the um Noah Samson one,
I was never going to like this one. >> Commentary community.
>> And you could make the argument that Noah reached like
like half a million viewers or something of people. Idubbbz is
a pathetic basement dwelling troll with a audience of exclusively
hate watchers and his not popping off on any social media site.
the amount of damages that could have possibly been done here.
It it's entirely based upon like uh the personal gripe in my
opinion. I don't think there's any damages.
Uh but this is about
all I can say
at least for now.
>> Yeah, it's all snarkers hate watchers. His money is
dwindling. He lives in a Canadian tundra. >> I'm sorry
that the >> I just don't see it as necessary and you're
not going to you're not going to sway me on that one. Stream
is so short. I wish I could give you a lot more. >> Don't
you think it's concerning that you basically have to like tell
your audience instead of telling your audience this is wrong
and like explain the principle? You basically have to go, "No,
no, no. We already this guy's life. No, no, no. We already we
already totally destroyed this guy. He has nothing left to take."
Like, isn't that concerning to you at a base level? Like I you're
not making any principled argument. You're basically just going,
"We already this guy up enough. We've already like bullied this
guy enough. We this guy up enough." Going any further is like
really it doesn't even make sense, man. It's like inefficient,
right? That that reminds me of when people get on Hassan's ass
for when he says something along the lines of like, "Well, I
don't even think this is like the right strategy, right? When
people say, "Oh, well, you know, all settlers should be killed."
And he goes, "I don't even think that makes sense as a strategy."
Well, shouldn't you be able to explain principally why it's bad,
too? I think you should be able to, right? I don't mind it if
you just do it on one level. If you say, "Well, guys, this guy's
like kind of owned already. Why would we do this?" Kind of gives
him just a chance to come back. But you have to say why it's
bad, too. But if you say why it's bad, if you say why, you would
be principally against it. If you really go into trying to convince
your audience of this, then you have to explain why you were
for other lawsuits. You have to explain why you've avoided criticism,
this exact criticism on how supporting Ethan Klein through those
initial lawsuits is probably going to lead to additional ones,
right? There's a whole bunch of things that come along with it
that he doesn't want to do, that Nicholas wants to avoid. And
so he can't he can't actually have the principal conversation
with his audience why this is bad, how it trickles down.
So instead he just goes, "Well, actually lots of people been
getting sued and we're kind of just it's just the way it is,
man."
That's what he has to say
Loser. Has he considered trying to change things, not just accepting
how things are. Actually trying to do stuff is like gay and cringe
to Nicholas Dioro. Like trying to make a difference, gay and
cringe. Trying to be a good person, gay and cringe. Trying to
make any change in the world. whatsoever. That's kind of like
the first one. Actually, I'm not going to say that. Not going
to say gang cringe again, but you you get the idea, right? It's
like trying, making an effort, being a good person who's trying
to build something. That's gang cringe, guys. Don't do that.
That's gross. Could you imagine trying to change things? Could
you imagine trying to make a difference in any way? No. NO. NO.
I just like laughing as the world burns.
Clowns.
You should have to wear clown makeup if you do this kind of commentary,
to be honest with you. I just I'm just going to sit here like
a jester as the world burns. [screaming] You should have to wear
clown makeup. Okay,
it's just it's a total joke. And I get it. We all want to just
have fun. We all just want to say like, "Ah, it's all funny and
I don't really care. You know, I'm a total nihilist." I understand
the the want to do that. I understand that it it's less serious.
It doesn't mean anything. If you up it's not a big deal. I totally
get the impulse. I get where it comes from. I don't respect it.
I, by the way, I [__] it up all the time. I say stuff
that's wrong all the time.
It doesn't hurt that bad. All you say is, "Well, I was wrong
there. My bad." And you keep going trying to create this whole
idea that you're like invaluable, that you don't ever get anything
wrong, that you never really spend any time trying to figure
out how to be better, how to correct your previous mistakes.
That's insane. It's worthless, man. It's It's worthless.
Sucks. Anyway, >> finish this up. >> Resume
the regularly scheduled content
on Thursday again. >> And that's basically what Ethan said.
My perspective is you won the court of public opinion dramatically
over the course of like a year and a half. I don't see what winning
the court actually provides you with other than just like twisting
the knife even further. And I'm sorry it's so short,
but we will be back.
And I appreciate you being here for this important announcement.
It's like beating a dead corpse to me. It's like pissing on a
Have a good day, everyone. So yeah, that is the uh the Idubbbz
lawsuit thing. That's the That's the big news that's there. Uh
this is very unex This should not be like a nuclear take to you.
I'm I'm sure the same people who were mad at me last time are
going to still be mad at me this time. Uh but yeah, it doesn't
really matter to me. That's just my take. So, we can agree to
disagree or not. I don't really care. Anyway, ladies and gentlemen,
let's see where he's been recently. This is the Chud the Builder
>> Yeah, I don't care anymore. Okay, where are we going
next? What are we doing next? I think I had a son reaction to
>> I do plan on fighting against this.
>> Bro is opening new fronts like he's Israel. No, literally.
What the I mean
is almost the most spiritual. >> It's almost like he's
Israel on the >> guys. It's almost like >> Ian Ja
aka >> It's almost like we could call this guy he's like
some kind of internet version of Israel or some guys. He's like
he's like Israel on the internet or something. Oh my Oh my god.
>> I will say that
it it worries me what it means for the commentary community.
Uh, but this is about all I can say, at least for now. [snorts]
I'm sorry that the stream is so short. I wish I could give you
a lot more grease, but I will resume the regularly scheduled
content. >> I think it's pretty crazy that if you're like
legitimately a mentally disturbed person and you just like lucked
in to uh unfathomable amounts of money, you can just consistently
be a demon and just sue people and try to bury them in costly
litigation over and over again. And especially if you like especially
if you're capable of of reaching an audience that's like constantly
demanding and rewarding you for for bullying other people through
this sort of frivolous litigation then you can kind of keep it
going. I mean >> you said your daily I is real high yet
I is real high is real high is real high. Yes I have. Yes I have.
>> And maybe your audience shrinks over time but you just
like keep it going for as long as you have money. I find it very
strange that there's no repercussions against this sort of thing.
What is this? Ethan Klein is a raffle coward now he's doing swinging
items in his life. He's made an entire career to talk about people
and now he can't doing everyone talks back. I'm sure the course
will love seeing clips of Ethan saying he will never stop harassing
them. He loves to go after people he assumes don't have money
to fight back. >> Yes, this all all ties in to the exact
characterization we've had of Ethan for a very long time. He
is a total he is a totally spineless
totally spineless coward. He cares about his internet reputation
which he has himself destroyed and he will sue people. He literally
the lawsuits will continue until morale improves. Okay. He can't
stop. He can't stop torturing his own reputation, his own career,
and he blames everybody else for it.
Worst kind of crybully.
>> Yeah, that one is actually really weird. Like that this
this one is like such a strange case cuz like what's the
Like Idubbbz didn't do the defamation? A a whole ass third party,
a separate person did, but you can't go after them cuz you're
afraid. So you're just choosing to go after the person who who
put the statement on screen. Is that what it is? He's suing Ian
for showing this message on stream. Yeah, I don't think that
is going to hold in a court of law. >> It'll depend on
basically it has to be I think it would have to be interpreted
as his opinion as him sharing that opinion himself, right?
Like I understand why the law would be this way, why there would
be laws or some sort of cutout for you can't say, well, I'm quoting
this person who said this and you could just make a defamatory
statement with no bearing towards yourself. If you do say, I
disagree with this entirely, it feels a little different.
And I don't know what they would do to give the other impression
or what they would argue. Maybe it goes to the court and they
just, you know, they say, "Well, you left it on screen for hours
and that doesn't make me think that you have a different impression.
Makes me think you actually believe it and you just said otherwise
to cover yourself." Possible. Possible. This is the PPP tweet
in response to the Idubbbz stuff.
>> Ian Washburn once said, "Either all speech is okay or
none of it is." The implication being in a free society, we must
tolerate some speech we find distasteful, disgusting, or even
untrue in order to preserve our general liberties. Ian Ja has
since stated that after he matured, he believes none of it is
okay, and any speech that offends anyone for any reason is unacceptable
and should be punished. Wait, has Idubbbz said this?
That would be particularly if he said it. Still though, even
if I I don't necessarily believe Idubbbz has said precisely this,
but even if Idubbbz had said this, okay, even if that were all
the case, you still wouldn't want him punished under your country's
laws because you wouldn't want to be exposed to that same punishment
from somebody who hates you,
right? We all understand.
We all understand this that even if this were Idubbb's opinion,
this is like the Hassan thing where people are like, "Well, Hassan
Hassan supports like authoritarian governments, so it's maybe
it's not that bad that the government's going." No, shut up.
The precedent is bad. Setting the precedent is bad. That's what
erodess your institutions. That's what erodess your liberties,
your freedoms, your
So even if it's some that you don't like, that you don't respect,
and that is honestly corrosive to your rights and liberties,
you still don't want them attacked on the same grounds.
Okay? It's important. It's important that you stand up and say,
"No, no, don't do that."
He moved to Canada, a country that sadly agrees with his newfound
views. It is hard to find any sympathy for the position he finds
himself in, especially considering he was signal boosting perhaps
the worst thing you could say about anyone, let alone a former
best friend. that they their own children in a in a context where
CPS had been called for BS reasons and you justified the CPS
call to millions of people. Oh god, he
Oh man,
really
falling back to the skulls, the CPS, the CPS and the skulls.
That's That's a little crazy
of all people. I again
I'll say because I do this throat clear quite often but I'll
do it one last time. I don't think CPS should have been called
on him. I don't support CPS being called on him. I think that
he is a who who basically allowed it to happen to himself by
yapping on the internet about his family. But even so, I still
don't think it should have happened.
I would never give him a pass. saying this is if you think Idubbbz
justified the CPS call, this is you PPP
justifying this lawsuit. Right?
Now, I I'm I'm sure you would argue that you're just explaining
why it happened, right? Which is what Idubbbz was doing. But
if you're going to say that this explanation, this description
of why this happened is a justification for Idubbbz when he talks
about why CPS was called on Ethan Klein, then you yourself are
justifying these
which maybe that's actually where he's going. So, hold on. I'll
I'll I'll remain calm. undecided. He smuggly believed because
he was on the right side of history that his victory was inevitable
and any despicable tactic was justified against enemies of progress,
i.e. whoever Hassan disagrees with. There is much shaden fraud
to relish in seeing someone who believes others speech should
be silenced being silenced themselves. It is very easy for me
to laugh at this situation and say you reap what you sow and
play stupid games, win stupid prizes.
I would say that could be true. I I you know I'm a partaker.
I'm a I'm a sh and fraud enjoyer.
But usually when it's basically using a mechanism that could
be weaponiz that could be weaponized or wielded against me. I'm
not as big a shad and fraud enjoyer, you know, like I Shad and
Freud don't care. Don't care. German's a fake language. So
suffice to
if I'm like in an industry, right? Let's say I'm I'm I run a
software company and there's some big anti-software bill coming
through, some big like anti-software as a service bill, some
big anti-AII bill and I'm an AI company. I don't laugh because
that bill is being proposed to go after one of my enemies. I
don't laugh because people found a a neat litigation loophole
to go after one of my competitors, right? When I know that that
exact loophole could be used to go after me, I go, "Oh,
actually, today is the day where I stand up and say that's wrong."
As much as I might hate that other company, hate that other
when I see myself exposed in the same way and not in a genuine
way, not in a way that I'm breaking the law and this other person's
breaking the law and we should both be over. Not like that, but
in a way where it's obvious that this person just wants to silence
criticism. Yeah, I'm not going to I'm not going to say you reap
what you sow. I'm not going to say play stupid games, win stupid
prizes. I'm not going to say around and find out. And that just
seems like obvious. That should be obvious to everybody.
But maybe not. Maybe not. However, it doesn't change the fact
I believe in the same things that Ian Washburn ONCE BELIEVED.
OH MY GOD, we're bringing it back. We're bringing it back. I
want a society where people feel free to criticize anyone or
anything, no matter how rich or powerful they may be. Where people
can make jokes and offend anyone without fear or of fear of financial
ruin or imprisonment. Private attacks on speech are just as serious
as attacks from the state. None of us want to live in a world
where rich petty private tyrants like Ethan Klein can police
speech or and silence criticism with lawfare and produce a chilling
effect on broader expression. I cannot for those reasons support
this lawsuit in principle.
Well, I I think actually the thing you do here, the thing that
is standing on principle here is starting to mock Ethan Klein
for being a neurotic freak all the time. Starting to go through
all the on him, making fun of him, mocking him, making him look
like a loser. just make the internet aware of who he is. But
again, PPP is in Canada and I'm sure he's going to be actually
quite terrified to do that. Justifiably so, I guess, that Ethan
Klein might go after anybody who does this to him who who attacks
him in this way in Canada. Is I am still an American citizen
living in Canada? I would assume so. Yeah. BPB continues, "I
was born a Canadian citizen and have no choice but to live under
the tyranny of these laws that one day may be used to silence
me and destroy my livelihood." Idubbbz, however, has an easy
solution to all of this. All he has to do is simply move back
to America into the loving embrace of freedom and Donald Trump.
The lawsuit judgment will be uninforceable against him from a
foreign state due to the speech act.
Um, interesting. I'm trying to think trying to think of how this
would go. I wonder what would happen with his wife. Is is Ana
like an American citizen fully? Like is she or does she have
like um a green card or whatever? Cuz that's actually probably
their best solution. I'll be honest that like moving back to
America would be the best solution for them.
Not even joking. Yeah, I know that's probably what's going on
is their whole family's in Calgary or whatever and that's probably
why they're there.
But I'm saying it isn't her speech. Yes, but obviously hold on.
Obviously
he's not going to move and leave his whole family in Calgary.
That would be stupid, right? What do you mean it isn't her speech?
I'm saying obviously you'd want to make sure everybody can move
or else that's not really a solution. Okay. Afterwards, he should
repent of being a tyrannical freedomhating fsler and kiss the
soil in America with joy treasuring the freedom that so many
others in this world will never have. He does not need your donations
or even moral support because all he needs to do is go home.
He would never do the same for any of us either. I'm an internet
clown for a living and ba for a living basically a professional
troll and so don't want to have to be serious and shouldn't be
taken as such. But if you wanted my post take, here it is. Hey,
I'm not a fan of the I'm personally not a fan of the just move
discourse, right? That's not I'm not a huge fan of that.
I'm a huge fan of And by the way, I think PPP would take this
route. If Ethan Klein were not neurotic and suing anybody who
criticizes him, especially those who criticize him aggressively
and affusively and vehemently,
if he weren't taking that route, I think PBB would just go, "Well,
I'm going to start on this guy hardcore."
I think that's what would happen, right? But now he's got to
pick a lane.
And the second PPP
doesn't go after, he's inclined for this, the second he doesn't
go, "Okay, now you are my target. Now you are the guy we're making
fun of. You're the guy threatening everyone's speech. You the
second he doesn't do that, how long is it going to be until the
quartering sees that and goes, "Well, I've got a bunch of money.
I don't like you guys talking about me. I got a bunch of money."
How long is it going to be? I hope people understand that this
is the precipice. We stand on the precipice,
man. Okay, I think I've got a couple Reddit threads on people
discussing this decision. Give me a second.
Canadian defamator defamation law H3H3 has a surprisingly low
hurdle to clear to to clear to establish a case. He only needs
to prove three things. The text was defamatory calling someone
easily qualifies. It clearly referred to him and it was published
to a third party. Your Twitch viewers downloading/watching the
stream. Once H3H3 proves those three things, the law presumes
the statement is false and malicious. The burden of proof completely
flips on Idubbbz, the streamer to defend himself. Just quoting
someone is not a legal defense. A common misconception online
is that you are safe if you include a disclaime disclaimer like
I'm just quoting what someone else said or this quote is from
an anonymous user. Well, hold on. I think this person's doing
a little a little chat magic. What I think is important to clarify
with Idubbbz is he says I do not believe this. I do not think
this is true.
I disagree with this
That is an important thing to highlight. No, it's not going it's
not doing the Candace Owens things of like, well, I'm just quoting
someone else, man. You know what I mean? Under Canadian common
law, the repetition rule states that repeating a lielist statement
is just as legally actionable as inventing it. Saying someone
else told me Mr. Smith is carries the exact same liability as
saying Mr. Smith is a
correct and this is why Ethan has gone ahead with it. He'd also
he'd also win if this was a UK case, too. Okay. I So, I do believe
that in Canadian defamation law broadly, you have to prove that
like why you think it's true essentially why you think the statement
is true. Right. Now, I think it's important to say that he clarified
that it wasn't true.
Yes. Okay. Ethan is taking the heated socks ways. The heated
socks ways. I I
Does anybody who's literate watch this podcast? Why do I have
to I read these things and it's like awful. The graveling Casey
Tron style apology from Anie and her husband will be legendary.
You are a psychopath, Mrs. Incomplete. You are a psychopath.
You are a total psychopath.
You are a complete not